on the mound for the tigers matt matty
fourth start his record is one and two
got his first win at cleveland tim still
having an above average year ops plus
over 100 but it's not the same robust
number as he's had the past couple of
seasons although he's starting to hit it
better and this ends up in center field
that's a hit in seventh straight for ta
he is four for ten in the series
and i would think tim would be going
here
so if manning does have a good move to
first base we're liable to see it
gavin in the air left hand side badou
can't get there
back to back hits to open the ball game
the sox have scored in both first
innings in this series and they're well
on their way here
the one two
hard shot to short
they turn two
the one-two
fly ball left field
akil badu camps under it that's a nice
job by matt manning he got out of an
early jam a double play and a lazy fly
lucas giolito on for his 17th start his
era at 384 a lot of strikeouts 111 and
93 and two thirds very few walks
up the middle nice backhand play and
they throw it wide
garcia got to it but then pulled abreu
off the bag and akiel badu has himself
an infield single
there goes badou the throw down from
collins won't be in time another stolen
bag his 13th of the year for akil badu
one and one to robbie grossman
up the middle that'll get the job done
tigers lead it
a little small ball for detroit here in
the first
the 2-2
a chopper to first
scope will take it himself
and for the second straight inning matt
manning avoids any damage does a nice
job maneuvering through some troubled
waters and a one-nothing tigers lead
the 2-1
that's ripped and that's a fair ball
into the left-field corner
candelario will gallop to third haas has
another extra base hit oh hum here we go
again for eric haas
here's harold castro
you're just gonna have to
shorten your stroke up
to get the wood on it
like that up the middle a base hit
one run is home
haas holds it third the bases remain
loaded and an rbi single from harold
castro
everybody inches to the edge
of their seats
for a keel badoo and the base is loaded
big pitch coming here
it's on its way
ripped to right
plenty of grass
haas is home
cameron's home
the dude's got to put on the brakes at
second base a two-run double for the
outstanding rookie to make it four
nothing
jose abreu who hit a ball 111 miles an
hour in the first inning
that's a fair ball into right field and
tim anderson is gonna score it's four to
one here in the third
long way to go in this one and jose is
starting to hit the baseball hard here's
garcia
in the air left hand side
badou is underneath
abreu from third races home and the sox
get a run it's 4-2 here in the third
haas on a fastball lifts it to right
eaton back at the track adam eaton makes
the catch of the scoreboard
nice play by adam and the throw to first
is in time and a crash landing into a
double play candelario out and adam
eaton may have just saved the day for
the sox in right field what an effort
from eaton and a tip of the cap for
giolito
two two
struck him out on the slider third k for
lucas
one two
there is the slider onto the beach and
two strikeouts in the inning
fastball to the corner for strike three
and lucas three strikeouts in the inning
[Applause]
cabrera to short t.a long peg he got him
wow a rainbow from shortstop
for route number two
the 1-1 down the right field line and
into the corner a three-hit day for
jamer candelario it's an rbi double and
it's a clutch add-on run for detroit
here in the fifth
100th pitch for giolito to right field
and a base hit for ericos candelario
will try and score
the throw is cut off and the tigers get
another one here in the fifth to make it
6-2 as erik has continues his red-hot
hitting
the 1-2
he went
yes sir he did
a couple of strikeouts for joe jimenez
here in the eighth
tim to right field that's a base hit
billy hamilton loses his hat and gets a
couple of bases sox have first and third
nobody out in a four-run game in the
ninth great to get the three-run home
run but we know this got to keep the
line moving right here with jose
jose drives this ball to left field batu
at the wall it is gone
this is a one-run ball game
uh-oh
well we told you that jose had one
at-bat in our ballpark where it looked
like things had turned around
and he got a slider this time and got
out in front of it and it was a no
doubter but dude just looked up couldn't
do anything about it and suddenly
it's a one-run game
three hits in the inning
vaughn sends one to right
one pitch and cisnero does the job
tigers win the series from chicago they
beat him 6-5 on the 4th of july